ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش ملفنا الثانيه
قراره وزراء الخارجيه العرب بعوده سوريا
الى مقعدها بجامعه الدول العربيه نال
اعتقادا من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي اوضحت ان دمشق لا تستحق هذه الخطوات
البيت الابيض اوضح ان واشنطن لن تطبع
العلاقات مع نظام بشار الاسد وان عقوبتها
على سوريا ستطل ساريه المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه فيدان باتل اوضح للصحفيين ان
واشنطن لا تعتقد ان سوريا تستحق اعادتها
الى جامعه الدول العربيه في الوقت الحاضر
موضحا ان بلاده تعتقد ان شركاء العرب
يعتزمون استخدام التواصل المباشر مع الاسد
بالضغط من اجل حل الازمه السوريه مضيفا
انا واشنطن تتفق مع حلفائه على الاهداف
النهائيه لهذا القرار كما حظ اعضاء في
الكونغرس من الحزبين او اعضاء في الكونجرس
من الحزبين حظوا وشجعوا الاداره الامريكيه
على استخدام العقوبات لمنع التطبيع مع
الاسد معتبرين ان اعاده سوريا الى مقعدها
في الجامعه العربيه خطا استراتيجي فادح
نحن نتفق مع شركائنا في الاهداف النهائيه
وكنا نتشاور معهم بشان خططهم ونوضح اننا
لن نقوم بتطبيع العلاقات مع نظام الاسد
وان عقوباتنا على سوريا ستظل ساريه
المفعول نحن ملتزمون في العمل من اجل
التوصل الى حل سياسي تحت رعايه مجلس الامن
التابعي للامم المتحده
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي ومن دمشق عبد
الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم ضيوف
الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك
استاذ ايهاب استاذ ايهاب ما هي اسباب
استياء الاداره الامريكيه من عوده سوريا
لمقعادها بالجامعه العربيه بمعنى ان هل
السبب الحقيقي
بالعوده
لمقانون قيصر بالعوده للعقوبات بالعوده
الى حقوق الانسان في سوريا ام ان الوضع او
السبب الحقيقي هو سبب استراتيجي لان
واشنطن تخاف من ان تتراجع او ان تفقد
حضورها في المنطقه استراتيجي ام حقوقي
اهلا بحضرتك استاذه ريمو اهلا بالضيف وبكل
المشاهدين هناك في الواقع
وجهتنا نظر في هذا الامر وهو ما يتفقان
ويتفقان ويثيران في نفس الاطار الفكره
الاولى فكره حقوقيه بمعنى ان هناك جرائم
كثيره من وجهه النظر الامريكيه طبعا
ارتكبت منذ عام 2011 وحتى الان
استدعت ان يكون هناك تدخل امريكي في الشان
السوري بشكل كبير لحمايه المدنيين
السوريين عن طريق طبعا قانون القيصر وفرض
العقوبات الى اخره
وقرر مجلس الامن اثنين اثنين خمسه اربعه
والامر التنفيذي الامريكي 13
894 على ما اتذكر الرقم
بتطبيق العقوبات المتعلقه بقانون قيصر
والتي فرضت على كثير من الكيانات والاشخاص
السوريين الذين ترى واشنطن انهم طالعين في
طبعا يعني الاعتداء على الشعب الس وري
بشكل كبير
هذا جانب الجانب الاخر
وهو المتعلق ايضا بفكره الاستراتيجيه
الامن القومي الامريكي وهذا جبل للسؤال
النصف السؤال الثاني لحضرتك بمعنى ان
واشنطن اليوم وطبقا لقانون القيصر مثلا
يسمح للرئيس الامريكي ان يرفع العقوبات
مباشره عن سوريا وعن كل من يتعامل مع
سوريا على نظام السوري يعني في حال اذا ما
راى الرئيس الامريكي مباشره ان هناك
اتجاه
ايجابي من الحكومه السوريه الحاليه
لحل الازمه التي هي حادثه هناك بالشكل
السياسي والدبلوماسي طبقا لقرار مجلس
الامن الذي ذكرناه قبل قليل
وتبقا لما يراعي مصالح الامن القومي
الامريكي يعني ممكن
في اطار تراجع نفوذ الامريكي ان تبقى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه منتظره
متراقبه وليس ان تكون في تحديد ما يناسبها
من اطر سياسيه اسمح لي ان ناخذ وجهه النظر
السوريه كذلك من الداخل السوري فيما يخص
هذا الموضوع استاذ عبد الحميد حضرتك كيف
تقرا هذا الامريكي لا نعلم ان كانت توصيف
استياء دقيق لانه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قالت نتفهم شركائنا العرب وفيما
بعد قالت نحن لا نرى بان عوده سوريا
لمقادها لا نظن بانه يمكن ان يكون ايجابي
وبعدها قالت سنراقب سننتظر ما الذي توجه
واشنطن من هذه التصريحات
مساء الخير لحضرتك
المشاهدين اعتقد انا من هنا من دمشق بان
الاستياء الامريكي هو الطبيعي الاستثناء
كان ان تكون ان تقول الولاد المتحده
الامريكيه نحن ندعم شركاءنا بحدود معينه
وبالتالي التاريخ العلاقات السوريه
الامريكيه قبل 2011 لم يكن ايضا ايجابيا
كما في غيره من العلاقات بين الدول الذي
يبدو من موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي قراءه اوليه انه موقف متخبط يقولوننا
من ناحيه بانهم هم يراقبون ما يحدث
ويقولون من ناحيه اخرى لن نطبع ويقولون
باننا ناقشنا هذه الخطوات مع شركائنا في
المنطقه اريد ان اشير الى ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في الموضوع السوري
تحديدا هو عنوان لها في استراتيجيتها وفي
مناطق نفوذها الحيويه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط عموما حين اقدم الجانب التركي على
خط بالتوجه الى سوريا وهو العضو الاطلسي
وهو الحليفه المتحده الامريكيه والى ما
هنالك لم تتمكن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من فنيه الجانب من ثني جانب
التركي عن التوجه لبحثا عن مصالحه فيما
يتعلق بسوريا وبما يتعلق بامنه القومي
اليوم العربي حين ناقشوا منذ ان حمل الملك
الاردني قبل اكثر من عام خطه الخطه
الاردنيه او المبادره الاردنيه الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومسمى الى
موسكو ايضا لماذا لم يمنع
الجانب العربي من هذا التوجه قال ما اريد
قوله هو ان اليوم مجمل التحولات في
المنطقه تشي بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن خلال السلوكيات والخيارات
المستقله التي ابدتها بعض العواصم العربيه
ليس باتجاه سوريا بل قبل ذلك باتجاه
خياراتها السياسيه المستقله بالعلاقاتها
الدوليه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه وتاثيرها
ونفوذها لم تعد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قادره على وضع الخط وضع خطوط
الحمر وتنفيذها باتجاه شركاء وحلفائها بعد
ان تاكدوا بان الشريك الامريكي شريك غير
امين غير مطمئن وبالتالي الاستاذ ايهاب
استاذ ايهاب ضيفي استمعت له يقول بانه لم
تعد واشنطن كما كانت لم تعد تضع خطوط حمر
لم تعد تفرض لانه هناك ازمه ثقه وحضرتك
تعلم بانه هناك ادارات تتالت وهناك ملفات
هناك بعض الاستفهامات حول المواقف
الامريكيه في السنوات السابقه كلها فهل
هناك تخبط في الاداره في هذه الاداره ام
ان هناك فعلا كما يقول ضيفي تراجع نفوذ
امريكي في المنطقه
يعني هو من هذا على ذاك من وجهه نظري
الشخصيه هناك محاولات اولا لنتفق على شيء
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سواء كانت
الاداره السابقه دونالد ترامب او الاداره
الحاليه هما تسعيان لايجاد حل سياسي
ودبلوماسي نهائي في سوريا دون اراقه
المزيد من الدماء
وهم الادارات او هما الادارتان تعتقدان ان
تطبيق قانون قيصر يتصق مع قرار مجلس الامن
22254 وان المخاوف الامريكيه المتعلقه
باستمرار نظام بشار الاسد بالتعاون مع مع
روسيا وايران يشكل تهديدا للامن القومي
الامريكي طبعا بجانب
ما بني عليه قانون قيصر من الاعتداءات على
المواطنين السوريين بالشكل الذي صورت معه
طبعا اكثر من 60 الف صوره وتم بناء عليها
صور تعذيب الى اخره وتم استصدار قانون
قيصر فبالتالي واشنطن تسير في اتجاهين في
اتجاه الحقوقي والاتجاه المتعلق بمخاوفها
الاستراتيجيه من تنامي النفوذ
ولكن ايهاب طالما حضرتك وذكرنا منذ
البدايه قانون قيصر طيب خلينا ندخل مثلا
بطريقه عمليه كيف ستتعامل واشنطن مع عوده
سوريا لمقعدها في الجامعه العربيه نحن
لدينا قانون قيصر وقانون قيصر ترتبت عليه
عقوبات شديده وكبيره وبالغه الاهميه ولكن
في المقابل مع عوده سوريا السفير احمد ابو
الغيط يقول بانه عوده سوريا لتلزم الدول
بتطبيع علاقاتها ولكن لا تحرمها فبالتالي
هناك دول ستعيد علاقاتها ستطبع مع سوريا
ستسحب ان كانت لها عقوبات ستسحبها ستستثمر
لا نعلم مستقبل هذا هذه العلاقات فكيف
سيكون موقف امريكا من كل هذا
هنا السؤال الصعب الذي ستجيب عنه خطوات
الاداره الامريكيه خلال الفتره القادمه
بالتعاون مع شركائها العرب يعني امريكا
اعلنت تفهمها لهذه الخطوات ولكن هي تعارض
التطبيق وهذا يعني انها مستمره في تطبيق
قانون قيصر طيب هل سيكون هناك عقوبات على
الدول العربيه التي سترغب في تحسين
علاقاتها الاقتصاديه والتجاريه مع سوريا
نعلم ان قانون قيصر دخل في تفصيلات
الشديده جدا فيما يتعلق بامور التعاون
والشركات الى اخره والعقوبات التي ستفرض
على هذه الدول والجهات وهنا نعود الى
السؤال او الفكره التي طرحها الضيف الكريم
من من دمشق انه هل واشنطن ما زالت لديها
القدره على ان تفرض قانون قيصر بالقوه
وتفرض هذه الخطوط الحمر ام لا هذا ما
ستجيب عنه القدرات الامريكيه الدبلوماسيه
خلال الفتره القادمه اللهم الا اذا كان
هناك استثناء مبطنا تحت الطاوله مع الدول
العربيه لاعطاء فرصه للجهود العربيه عن
طريق جامعه الدول العربيه لاحداث الحاله
التي نص عليها ايضا قانون قيصر بامكانيه
ان يكون الرئيس الامريكي ولوحده مخولا
برفع كامل العقوبات عن سوريا اذا ما وجد
توجهها جديدا من قبل النظام السوري لاحداث
حاله سياسيه في البلاد تؤدي الى انهاء عبد
الحميد هل يمكن ذلك هل ترى بان بوابه
الجامعه العربيه قد تكرر تكرس وتقرب اكثر
سوريا وتعيد لها علاقاتها مع المجتمع
الدولي
الجامعه العربيه كمؤسسه لا اعتقد ولكن انا
اعول على الرباعيه العربيه العواصم
الاربعه التي تبنت فكره المبادره وكسر
الحاجز النفسي والسياسي بالعلاقه العربيه
مع سوريا وبالتالي انا اعول على الرباعيه
العربيه على المملكه العربيه السعوديه لما
لها من ثقل ووزن وتاثير على المستويات
العربيه العربيه وفي سوريا بات التقدير
كبيرا لجهودها وكذلك القاهره وكذلك
الامارات الاردن فالعراق واعتقد بان
الخارطه العربيه من الرباعيه العربيه التي
طرحت على سوريا بشكل شفاف وتشخيص دقيق
للامراض التي تعاني منها سوريا والتي
ينعكس بعضها على الجوار العربي وعلى عموم
العرب مخدرات والكبتاجون
وبقيه التفاصيل الاخرى والجانب الامني
والجانب الانساني كل هذه التفاصيل ربما
ايضا باتت نقطه التقاء بين سوريا وتلك
الدول العربيه وبالتالي نعم اعول على
الرباعيه العربيه في من خلال التفاعل الذي
يجب ان يكون بين دمشق وبين هذه العواصم
العربيه في دفع الامور باتجاه ايجابي ا
اكثر وتحديدا فيما يتعلق الذاتي توافقات
مع الجانب الامريكي اولا وهذا ما تحدث عنه
ايضا بيان
سيد عبد الحميد صحيح ولكن اعذرنا على
المقاطعه يبقى دائما سؤال نحن نتحدث عن
الجامعه العربيه عن الدور العربي عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن ماذا عن
سوريا ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه ان يقدمه
النظام السوري لتحقيق اولا تقارب عربي
سوري لتحقيق بدء خطوات جديه لمحاوله
ازاله هذه العقوبات والبعض يسال في الواقع
انقل لك هذه النقطه بطريقه واضحه ما
المزاج السوري الحالي هل هو عربي هل هو
روسي هل هو ايراني نظام السوري الان يميل
او بوصلته باي اتجاه تحديدا
اذا تحدثنا عن سوريا
كاوساط
الى هنالك انا استطيع ان اجزم بانها مياله
الى الحاضنه العربيه وربما احدث هذا
التقارب العربي كثيرا من الامل والتفاؤل
في الاوساط عامه وبما فيها مؤسسه الرئاسه
السوريه ومؤسسه القياده السوريه لما يعني
ذلك من ان العامل العربي يمكن ان يكون
عاملا تحفيزيا عاملا مشجعا عاملا مطمئنا
لسوريا دوله وشعبا هذا جانب الجانب الاخر
في سؤالك الذي تفضلت به عن
اميز بين ما هو المطلوب وماذا يجب ان تكون
به ان تقوم به سوريا انا اعتقد بان
المطلوب من سوريا هي عناوين اساسيه واعتقد
ان الاجتماعات التي تطورت وصولا الى اعاده
سوريا الى مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه لم
تكن تحدث لو لم يكن هناك استجابه سوريه
واجوبه سوريه واضحه سلمت الى الجانب
العربي عن طريق وزير الخارجيه السوري
وبالتالي كان ربما الترجمه العمليه الاولى
لهذه التفاهمات ما حدث فجره امس بالغاره
التي قيل انها اردنيه على اكبر معمل واكبر
مهرب كبتاجون ومخدرات على الحدود السوريه
الاردنيه في الجنوب بالتالي القول ما هو
مطلوب من سوريا حقيقه هو عباره عن خارطه
الطريق واضحه ولا تحتاج الى كثير جهد
واعتقد بان بناء اصدقاء يحتاج الى ثنائيه
مشتركه من سوريا ومن العرب على حد دائما
بقيه والاكيد باننا سنكون امام هذا
الموضوع بتفاصيل انها اخرى اود شكركم جزيل
الشكر منه واشنطن ايهاب عباس المحلله
السياسي ومنزاج عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب
الصحفي شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات